wir sind jetzt hier an einem rübenfeld
und sind mit der letzten kultur für
dieses jahr mit der antrag beschäftigt
der über ruder hat jetzt hier schon
begonnen da sind alle ganz überrascht
wie hoch die erträge noch sind für die
extreme trockenheit die wir hatten wir
haben von erfüllen bis jetzt noch nie so
wenig regen gehabt die in diesem jahr
[Musik]
bisher vielleicht 30 prozent der ertrags
reduzierung gegenüber den letzten sehr
sehr guten jahr sind alle erstaunt dass
es mit so wenig wasser
doch noch mit über ein kilo gewicht sind
[Musik]
ja der ist maschine die 56 arbeitsgänge
gleichzeitig erledigen kann
früher wurden hier die zuckerrüben mit
der hand gerodet oder ausgegraben und
heute dieser rübenroder schafft das
alles mit einer überfahrt der fängt
zuerst an die blätter ab zu häckseln
dass die die blätter einfach weg sind
dann kommt messer dass die die die köpfe
abschneidet oder wenig zucker drin ist
und viele schädliche stoffe für die für
die zuckererzeugung in der fabrik
drinnen sind dann kommt das rote schals
oder läuft durch den boden und schlug
die zuckerrübe aus der erde heraus
dann wird sie über mehrere wahlgänge und
defender wird dann die blätter noch ein
bisschen getrennt und dann letztendlich
auf dem zu beruhigen oder gebogen wird
der oder
mit dem boom der von ihm weg land wo
diese dann bis zum verladen ein bisschen
transport gelagert werden
die rüben werden dann in zwei drei tagen
mit der lade maus auf einen lkw geladen
vom lkw gehen die dann in die
zuckerfabrik nach offstein dass eine
fabrik die größte fabrik der firma
südzucker
[Musik]